so yeah that's uh that's um
and then john boziack the uh what did
you call him in the podcast
it was um come on you had a great one
was the credit card or
some credit card king or oh dark what
was the name of the podcast
oh the dark the dark lord miami's dark
lord of credit card scams
pretty good good um that was good too
with the with the
the picture that with him with the
chains and everything um
yeah some guy contacted him he called me
up he's like yeah bro listen to this
[ __ ] guy contact me told me he wants
to give me like five grand or something
he was he was to basically teach him how
to commit
credit card fraud he's that's [ __ ]
nuts right i go don't do it and he goes
he goes
what i go don't do it he goes he goes no
i'm not going to do it he said
i i something's wrong that's something's
not right i said no
it may be legit he may legitimately say
hey i'll pay you
but when he gets caught in six months or
two two months
it's gonna i told him this is what what
what this is what will happen look i
know a guy that got an extra 10 years
because he was locked up for like or did
he get an extra five he was locked out
for 10 and got an extra five or he was
was doing five and he got 10. the point
is
you and i are selli's so you tell me hey
so he's about to get i'm about to get
out maybe two years you're gonna get out
in
a a couple months and you tell me man
listen my weed connect
but he got popped when i got cop popped
i used to buy weed from him you know not
a lot like this and that you know
you oh you can you could talk to my
you can talk to my um you can talk to my
cousin
uh whatever you know uh um juan
you can talk to my cousin juan i'll give
you his phone number so i write his
phone number yeah he can get your weed
no problem oh okay cool
you go you leave you start buying weed
from one
i don't hear from you no more six months
a year go by the weed that you're buying
from juan
turns into um it goes from being
marijuana
to cocaine oh yeah and now you guys are
running a cocaine conspiracy where
you're importing cocaine from mexico
and it's getting more and more it's 5
kilos 10 20 30 now it's [ __ ] 300
kilos
so almost two years goes by you get
pinched and when they grab
you and they grab juan they say hey how
did you even get connected with this guy
you're like some white guy you got
connected with this mexican guy how'd
that even happen
i mean that you're doing cocaine you
were you got pinched for like
you know weed or something and you say
oh
my old sally you know pablo
he uh he hooked me up with him well
guess who
guess who's named giovanni guess whose
name just got added to the conspiracy
so they come back and they say hey so
do you want to fight this and look
you're looking at maybe you're now
on by the way you're now on like a a
thousand pound or a thousand kilo
conspiracy
you want to go ahead and go to trial
with that you're already in jail for
cocaine this is like your fourth time
and this is federal
and you know we've already indicted you
and this guy's already cooperating
what do you think he's gonna say do you
think he's gonna say you it was just
started with weed or do you think he's
gonna be willing to say oh no no
he knew we were going to sell cocaine we
were holding his money
no he was he completely new we've been
trading emails and we've been trading uh
letters through the map you think that's
what he's going to say or do you think
he's going to cut you loose and say no
bro he thought he was just going to give
me
some a little a little weed connect what
do you think he's gonna say to get time
off
[ __ ] so how much are you saying so he's
singing how much time
how much time does so what kind of a
deal can we get can i get can i
you know that this guy's gonna please
pablo's saying listen
five years that's good i understand no
problem
takes a deal immediately yeah i mean
that happens i met that that guy
i met that guy god damn
that's an exact scenario i don't know if
he got five an extra five years or he
got 10 i think he got five i think he
was doing 10 and got an extra five that
was it
because he gave him a phone number so
you know what's gonna happen to you
you're out you're trading emails with a
guy you got on the phone and talked to
him
what are you gonna tell him oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i did tell him how to do
some cred like credit card fraud it
wasn't a big deal
you're done you're done you're now the
leader organizer
no no ask him ask him his lawyer is
saying to tell them
that he's the you're the leader
organizer you've already been
to prison multiple times we got a
podcast
it's over you're done people are crazy
man
right people but they don't think it
through that's the problem they just
reach out straight on the internet with
the paper trail everywhere and they all
think they're going to be gangsters when
they get caught because they watched
godfather
you're nuts you're not getting a slap on
the wrist
and look the cops are so are so busy
right now you could run a fraud right
now and go for a year or two
until you eventually get caught and you
think wow i had a good run no you didn't
no you just got higher and higher on the
on the guidelines that's all
you wish they i wish they'd caught me in
the first six months
i could have gotten probation maybe i
could have done a year but i went
so long and so hard by the time they
caught me
now you just better hope to god that
nobody gets caught doing fraud that even
has your phone number in there better
burn nothing
it's bad it's bad it's time to change
the number
to keep changing them yeah yeah it's
it's uh
that's right so all those people that
died oh
wow we got some scratch off merry
christmas
these are ten dollar holiday cash
blowout nice these are the [ __ ]
my wife won like if you get 200 bucks on
these one of these the other day you get
rich off that don't forget about me
no i i'm not gonna danny yeah yeah
he'll be like uh no i didn't i didn't
hit nothing
matt cox don't lie to the people out
there i've given you more money than
anybody else has
ever yeah not more than bank of america
all right what are we doing with what
are we doing about are we gonna do these
no what do you want to do with those
what are those what the [ __ ] are those
you bring some christmas presents
christmas
christmas you know we could do presents
okay so the first people
that the first emails that i get that
say in the in the um
in the subject that say you know watch
right
whatever the first four that that send
me an email to my email address
and subscribe to my channel matt cox and
inside true crime
um so i can comment on all the videos
like and comment on all the videos
so the first four people that email me
we can put the email
in your description right it's like
inside true crime
just tell them the email it's inside
it's inside true crime
um at gmail.com
right is that a guest it's at gmail.com
yeah
gmail.com sounds good yeah inside
aol.com right
at bankofamerica.net so
anyway these are watches but you got to
open one let's see one of those [ __ ]
the watchers are cool bro they're like
heavy come on
they're they're that's what i liked
about when i when the guy is this for us
is this a gift for us no it's not it's a
rolex absolutely not
no it's a wow they're called no they're
called standage
and it's from the guys in the uk but
what i like is that they're like
heavy like they're nice watches i've
been wearing this thing for three months
now looks like an aba looks like a watch
a pilot would wear
they're pretty cool bro and they're
heavy they're made of like stainless
steel they're
they're good watches pretty fancy it's
not my style but it's fancy fancy
it's nice that's nice yeah they come
with like ownership papers
oh you got the you got the papers what
are they what do these things cost
retail
um i don't know they're like three four
hundred bucks wait wait no no no no
they're like 500 bucks
because that's it's like they're like
350 um
euros that's like almost 500 bucks oh my
goodness
james well it's like 450 450.
nice and you're just going to give these
away to the first people because he sent
them to me
and he told me to give him away because
he was just like hey i like your channel
you got to do something it can't be just
the first person that emails you they
got to what
i just said what do you want to do what
do you what do you i mean
they gotta subscribe to all your [ __ ]
and uh yeah proof send a screenshot to
matt cox's first draft four people that
order a book
are getting to watch with the book so
now it's just now it's just confusing
i don't i yeah what i mean you're
killing me but i don't know yeah now we
don't know what the [ __ ] i don't know
what's going on somebody's
just trying to get you some more money
somehow i mean i i appreciate it's
christmas just
sorry [ __ ] it send it to the first four
jamoks that [ __ ] send an email what
is this
subject watch and matt will pick some
random emails four of them no i'll pick
the first four
the first four first four that's good i
mean the first four that say watch in
them that's good enough it's called
standage and you can go online he's got
a website it's
super cool man i think they're cool yeah
we got new concrete shirts too you can
buy
and uh you win nothing you just buy it
and you can rep concrete or not limited
there's only a couple there's no uh
there's no backhanded scam there it's
just you can buy it or not buy it no
giveaways
no games that was that a scam no games
no gimmicks no giveaways
send me their social security number
surprise you didn't jump on that